Oh, shit!
Yeah, I think
we're gonna get out of here.
Oh, shit!
-Don't move, don't move!
-Why?
Bulls have terrible eyesight
but they can sense motion.
You're thinking
of Jurassic Park.
No! I saw
a nature documentary
starring David Attenborough.
You're thinking of
Richard Attenborough
from Jurassic Park.
Vamos! Vamos!
Vámonos. Vámonos.
They're telling me to run.
If you run, you die!
Right, yes or no,
was Jeff Goldblum in it?
Oh my God.
It was Jurassic Park,
that's Jeff Goldblum.
Asshole.
Uh, hold on a second.
Wh-what's a Furby?
Well, that's haunting.
Why would someone
build that?
Run!
Sometimes I pinch myself
'Cause I don't know
Am I dreaming now?
-You're not dreaming, no
-I wanna stop the clocks
-And hold you close
-The, the scarf…
-Hold you close
-But I don't know how
The scarf!
Oh, the scarf.
Sigrit!
Crap! Hold on!
I can fix this!
And now the hamster wheel
is off to the races.
Keep singing!
This is not happening!
Oh, no!
Look out!
I'm in complete control!
Holy shit!
Oh, God!
Sigrit!
-Lars!
-Yeah!
Are you okay?
The elves must hate us!
We're hearing voices,
so they're not dead.
What?
-It's Vegas at its best.
-Wait a minute.
Is this that place
that was on The Real World?
Are you kidding me?
Oh my God, it's cra--
Hey, buddy! How you doing?
I'm good!
I feel,
I'm so much more relaxed.
Thank you, Helen.
I just feel like…
I'm excited,
and I feel relaxed,
and I'm ready to
party!
With the best of them
And I'm gonna go
Down to the river
Wow!
It looks like somebody's
really relaxing now.
What are you guys
talking about up here?
We are, um…
We're going to a restaurant
tonight, I know the owner.
You do?
Oh!
Helen knows the owner.
Big whoop.
Okay, let's go take a nap,
what do you say?
Baby
-Never leave you, Riley
-Look up
What he's really
Trying to say
Is get your head
Out of your ass
Listen to the goddamn
Qualified scientists
We really fucked it up
Fucked it up this time
It's so close
I can feel the heat big time
And you can act like
Everything is alright
But this is probably
Happening in real time
Celebrate or cry or pray
Whatever it takes
To get you through
The mess we made
'Cause tomorrow
May never come
Just look up
Turn off the shitbox news
'Cause you're about to
Die soon, everybody
Twinkle twinkle, little star
How much
Daddy needs a bar
Go to sleep, Maddy
Try to sing higher.
Maddy, go to sleep
-Go to sleep, Maddy
-It's not working though.
Maddy, go to sleep
Oh no, that made it worse.
-Well…
-She's not a clapper.
-She just won't stop.
-Listen to your daddy!
Your daddy said
go to bed, Maddy.
Your father is tired!
-That's not abuse.
-Yeah.
-It's borderline.
Alright.
You look like a paedophile
in this picture, number one.
Number two, it doesn't
even have a first name.
It just says McLovin.
What? One name!
One name?
-Who are you, Seal?
-Fogell?
This ID says
you're 25 years old.
Why wouldn't you
just put 21, man?
Seth, Seth, Seth.
Listen up, assface.
Every day, hundreds of kids
go into the liquor store
with their fake IDs
and every single one
says they're 21.
How many 21-year-olds
are there in this town?
It's called
a fucking strategy.
Let's stay calm.
Let's not lose our heads.
It's a fine ID.
It'll… It's gonna work.
It's passable, okay?
This isn't terrible.
It's up to you, Fogell.
He'll either think, "Here's
another kid with a fake ID,"
or, "Here's McLovin,
the 25-year-old
Hawaiian organ donor."
Okay? So what's it gonna be?
I am McLovin.
No you're not.
No one's McLovin.
McLovin's never existed.
It's a made-up dumb fucking
fairy-tale name, you fuck!
Oh, God.
Good morning, beautiful!
Last night was amazing.
You know, I was
just thinking in the shower,
when I look at the world
through your eyes,
it's like I'm seeing it
for the first time.
Natalie, I love--
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold that thought,
don't say another word.
Just get back into bed.
I don't think
we actually did anything.
-It cut to the next morning.
-What?
Get back here.
Okay.
Good morning, beautiful!
Last night was amazing.
You know, I was
just thinking in the shower,
when I look at the world
through your eyes,
it's like I'm seeing it
for the first time.
Natalie, I l--
Good morning, beautiful!
Last night was amazing.
You know, I was thinking--
In the shower, yeah.
Okay, everybody up.
Ms. Norbury had us
write out apologies
to people
that we'd hurt in our lives.
Alyssa,
I'm sorry I called you
a gap-toothed bitch.
It's not your fault
you're so gap-toothed.
Gretchen,
I'm sorry I laughed at you
that time you got diarrhoea
at Barnes & Noble,
and I'm sorry
I told everyone about it.
And I'm sorry
for repeating it now.
Laura, I don't hate you
because you're fat.
You're fat
because I hate you.
I just wish
we could all get along
like we used to
in middle school.
I wish that
I could bake a cake
made out of
rainbows and smiles
and we'd all eat it
and be happy.
She doesn't even go here.
Do you even
go to this school?
No. I just have
a lot of feelings.
Okay, go home.
…happened, I heard a scr--
Malcolm!
Oh, God!
Has anybody
tried to revive him?
He's got a knife
in his heart.
I don't think
he's revivable.
Should we pull it out?
No. It's a foot-long knife,
it's just, like--
Oh, God.
Wow! You should have
left the knife in
for the po-po, Colonel, man!
-I'll put it back.
-Don't.
Will you listen
to my husband?
He's a detective.
Yes, yes. What shall
we do, Mr. Officer?
For starters, let's stop
removing and reinserting
the murder weapon
into the victim's chest.
That was
my high school crush.
I swear to God, that's
my crush from high school.
-For real?
-Yeah.
-That's Maria Li, man.
-For real?
I haven't seen her forever,
man, I'm like…
I'm, like, shak--
Yeah, dude.
That's why I got quiet.
I promised myself
next time I saw her,
I was gonna ask her out.
-She may not remember me.
-Shoot your shot!
-You think so?
-Yeah.
I look like a shlub.
Ah, you look good, man.
-You think so?
-You should go do it.
"Hey, how are you?
Remember me?"
Yeah. Yeah, okay.
Alright, cool.
Alright, let me--
I'll vacuum your car, then
I'll get you out of here.
Can you hit that "On" switch
on the vacuum for me?
Thanks, man.
-Right here?
-Yeah, thanks, man.
Yeah, there's probably,
like, so many other guys--
Shit.
Shit! Oh, shit!
Shit, shit, shit.
What the fuck?
No, no, no.
Oh my God, turn it off.
What did you press?
Turn it off. What the fuck?
-I'm gonna get fired again.
-Oh, shit.
Give me your jacket.
Jacket, jacket.
Thanks, man.
Holy fuck. Why, why, why?
-What did you do?
-I just pressed "On."
Shit.
Oh, now that's Maria.
That's Maria.
-Holy shit.
-Hey, excuse me, sir?
Hi, hey, hi.
Um, do you know how long
an interior detail takes?